[Music]
t minus 10
9 8 7
6 5 4.
[Music]
the space race isn't just global
superpowers duking it out for bragging
rights and technological supremacy
anymore private companies lots of them
are rushing to commercialize not just
the final frontier
but the act of getting there i'm a
sports guy this is like march madness to
me
it's one and done i got one shot to get
to the end
or else i'm either going to fail run out
of money or be
be gobbled up by someone else and
whoever figures out how to make launch
safe
affordable and convenient is going to
take the next
giant leap
we choose to go to the moon in this
decade and do the other things
not because they are easy but because
they are hard
60 years into the space race the way we
leave earth has changed remarkably
zero all engine running liftoff
we have a liftoff 32 minutes past the
hour
space seemed like a vast black desert
but now we're ready to make the desert
bloom
i'm talking about opening space up to
business to private enterprise
opening space up to commerce and
experimentation and development
why to improve the quality of life on
earth
25 years after ronald reagan signed the
commercial space launch act
the desert has begun blooming i think if
you were a young person in 1969
you saw people walking on the moon and
50 years later we still haven't gone
back
i think that's a little disappointing i
think they took that their hopes and
dreams of their youth
and are applying in today's marketplace
and i think they're having a
fantastic success in the world of rocket
launch there are two very distinct races
going on
the first are the large rocket companies
like spacex
virgin galactic and blue origin jeff
bezos has reportedly invested
billions already in blue origin and will
invest billions more
[Music]
spacex has also raised billions of
dollars and acquired very large
contracts from nasa as well
in order to fund both development and
operations
of its vehicles liftoff of the spacex
falcon 9 rocket
but they aren't the only players in the
game there's a heated race picking up
between
small and medium launch companies
there's a subset of the community
not named spacex not named blue origin
trying to figure out
okay how can we get there fast companies
like rocket lab
relativity firefly and virgin orbit
right now there are more than 100 small
launch companies competing
not just to get to space but to see who
can get there
most reliably cheapest
and then repeat it over and over and
over again
and ideally end up with their business
in the black
because entire new industries rely on
these launch companies getting payloads
into
orbit and any missteps can spell
disaster
not just for a rocket but an entire
company
there is a 200 plus billion dollar
commercial space industry right now
today there are a couple of huge markets
that have been very profitable the most
profitable is a satellite industry
in 2018 the global space economy was
estimated to be around 360 billion
dollars
277 billion of that is a satellite
industry
which has actually grown over a hundred
billion dollars over the past decade
and for those satellites to get to space
they need to be launched on a rocket
global launches in 2018 increased by 46
percent
over the number of launches a decade ago
in many respects it's never been
easier to put a satellite into space in
terms of the cost
and the availability of rockets to ride
into orbit
and a new era of smaller cheaper
satellite technology
is creating this boom
once a year out in a desert of northern
utah the small satellite or smallsack
conference
comes to logan it has all the trademark
features of an industry trade show
bright lanyards tons of swag but the
deals happening here
are carving out what the future of the
space economy will look like
i've been coming to this conference for
20 years and seeing it grow from 300
people to over 3
000 so it is exciting to see that
transition as we move into the next
phase
traditional satellites are often
powerful behemoths
the size of school buses costing
hundreds of millions if not billions of
dollars to build
today the proliferation of small sats
cubesats
even nano sats can cost as little as ten
thousand dollars
and can be built with similar hardware
that goes into your cell phone
they range from the size of a rubik's
cube
up to about the size of a dorm room
refrigerator and so that's a big
difference
and so some of these launch ventures
want to launch a few dorm size
refrigerators and others want to launch
dozens of cubesats
and so they're trying to divide the
market that way
those satellites are providing imaging
of the earth they're potentially
providing telecommunications
services and they're attracting quite a
lot of investment
tens hundreds of millions of dollars
even billions of dollars
the earth's insatiable need for
communications and internet is
really what's driving this huge number
of satellites that are going into orbit
in the next
five to seven years there's going to be
thousands if not tens of thousands of
new satellites in orbit
in in the next five to seven years the
question is are they
able to actually provide business
services that
will be successful the idea is that
entirely new business models
as well as revenue streams will be
propped up by the data these small sats
collect
the imaging and data collected from
these small sats will be used by
everyone from hedge funds to telecom
giants
to the u.s government just think of how
much
photos you can get with your android or
iphone have improved from the first
generation to the current generation
similar things happening in small sets
market research says small smallsat
manufacturing will nearly double by 2020
with nearly 8 000 new small sats in
space by 2026.
the issue was always small satellites
have a lot of capability
but there's not a good affordable way to
get them into orbit
and that's where the small launch
companies see a promising business
the fact that a small launch vehicle is
much cheaper in total
than a large launch vehicle on the order
of five or ten million dollars as
opposed to
50 to 100 million dollars and
there are more customers say you have a
small sap that you want to launch into
orbit
think of the big companies like spacex
as a bus
and the small and medium launch
companies like rocket lab as a taxi
with large launchers you're at the back
of the bus after the needs of what's
called the primary which is the main
payload on the rocket
like a big government satellite your
small sat is just piggybacking off that
primary
since they bought the majority of the
rocket with small launchers like rocket
lab
you and your small sat can dictate more
of your terms on when
and how you'll fly and you'll pay for
the whole ride
so booking a taxi for a small sat gives
you more flexibility
about when and exactly where you want to
go into orbit
but it's more expensive sometimes
a ride share on a big rocket and the
chance to save on your launch expense
is more suitable depending on the
satellite its mission
and the budget far more important is the
orbital inclination
or the angle of the satellite's orbit
relative to the equator
it's much easier to move a satellite
into a higher or lower orbit
than to change its inclination and
that's why all launch customers
have to decide how their mission
priorities and budget
can align when choosing how to get to
space it's getting to the point
that hitching a ride on the really big
rockets
it works for some people it doesn't work
for all business cases
and so you've got smallest adventures
that say
we want our own rides those customers
will determine
which of these small rocket companies
succeeds and which of the companies will
fail
this is not the internet where you build
up a huge user base and then you figure
out how to monetize them later
launch doesn't work that way you've got
to build up a backlog of customers
out of the more than 120 small and
medium-sized launch companies out there
just one is successfully launching
rockets for customers right now
and that is rocket lab people can
actually rock on up to us and we'll fly
them
that's a great competitive advantage to
have over you know folks that are still
developing a vehicle
peterbeck's rocket lab has raised over
280 million dollars from outside
investors
with a valuation of more than one
billion dollars and is currently
flying a rocket every 30 days it looked
like
the hardest thing to do was to go from
zero to first successful orbital flight
but really going from first successful
orbital flight through to producing one
every month
has been equal amount of of stress and
energy and complexity and toughness
obviously we completed our test flights
and moved into full commercial
operations
with the first flight of its business
time and then
and then straight on the heels of that
we flew our nasa mission and now
uh we're you know we're building and
launching one vehicle every sort of 30
days every month
and while other rocket companies are
looking to build their customer base
rocket lab can't meet the rising demand
for launches
our biggest issue is is we can't build
enough rockets that is that is our
challenge
we've built four and a half acres of new
factories um and you know
we're pushing every in every direction
we can to to build more capacity
be fair that there aren't you know we
are the only dedicated solution
available in the marketplace right now
at an annually an affordable price
so we see a tremendous amount of demand
so the demand is there that's not the
issue the issue is figuring out how to
provide reliability
scale and cadence while keeping prices
as low as possible
and each company has its own approach
every company has a unique
way to building their rocket you know
whether they're using
liquid solids fuels or combination of
the two
whether they're 3d printing their stages
everyone has their
unique approach to getting to a rocket
however the bottom line is good business
in space
is exactly like good business on earth a
focus on customers
incremental successes and a vision
that's supported by a real business
model
is what works in space just as it works
on earth
one of the companies who believes they
have a successful business model is
firefly
a medium-sized launch company based out
of austin texas
so i'm going to run through this part of
the procedure okay please set bang bang
press logic to the next pressure
increment and we'll go in 10 psi
increments starting from ambient
with a window of one and so in the next
six months firefly is going to launch
this rocket we've been working on it for
four years now
and we're gonna have that cathartic
moment where we launched the rocket
everything's going to go great
but the outlook for firefly wasn't
always so rosy
this is a very difficult business there
are a lot easier ways to make money in
the world than
building a rocket company and you have a
lot of setbacks you have technical
setbacks you have financial setbacks
but the most challenging one for me has
been the financial setbacks
firefly like many other rocket companies
is familiar with financial setbacks
vector one of the more well-known launch
startups ran
into financial woes in the summer of
2019
and saw their ceo depart amid
uncertainty about the company's future
back in 2017 firefly then known as
firefly space systems
was saddled with financial instability
and filed for bankruptcy
that's when silicon valley investment
fund nowasphere ventures swooped in
bought their assets and rebranded the
company to firefly aerospace
i've learned a lot about the types of
investors that you want to have involved
in this
that learning has made us i think very
strong to to push through this time
as an investor and as sort of you know
one of the financial
sort of people behind the company i try
to encourage the team to think beyond
simply building a product
but building a business thank god we
went bankrupt
frankly we have a better product now i
have a better partner who lets me do
what i'm good at doing and he funds the
project
and i'm not off you know humping the
dot-com guy's legs
please give me another 100 000 now after
two years of r
d they're about to launch their first
rocket our plan is to have five launches
next year
all five of them will be from vandenberg
air force base in california
[Music]
but the next thing is start adding
technology
as an established company and
reusability and continuing to drive the
cost down
and we want to do things in a in a
different way
companies like firefly are hard pressed
to differentiate themselves to stand out
to investors
and attract customers we're
differentiated by our payload class even
amongst small launchers we're a big
small launcher
so our first rocket alpha is capable of
carrying a thousand kilograms whereas
our competitors are more in the
500 kilograms in less area that bigger
payload means they can service bigger
clients such as nasa
and other federal agencies like the u.s
air force
we are on track to be able to provide
nasa lunar lander capabilities
landing on the moon in the 2021 time
frame and these would typically be
launched
in early 2021
firefly has restructured and rebuilt its
organization from the ground up
but the question remains if they can
remain competitive
when it comes to price we currently have
a backlog of about 1.3 billion dollars
and a pipeline of over three and a half
billion dollars for our launch services
alone
if we fly according to our projected
flight rates
we expect to be cash flow positive by
the end of 2020.
we're very conscious of cost that's what
one of the fundamental tenets of new
space
so firefly will try to be competitive
with anyone and we take all competition
seriously that competition comes not
only from other small and medium launch
companies
but large ones as well like spacex who
announced a small sat solution
priced as low as 1 million dollars for
payloads up to 150
kilograms which equates approximately
fifteen thousand dollars per kilogram
to polar sunshine orbit coincidentally
that is exactly the same
as the firefly unit economics for our
alpha vehicle
firefly believes they can deliver
something that elon musk's space giant
cannot
unlike spacex where those satellites
will be one of many quite possibly one
of 60
our partners will have the same unit
economics but we'll have a much more
custom
dedicated offering it could be one of
four or one of five satellites in our
fairing
rideshare is not the best opportunity
for a lot of small satellite
customers in some ways it's like
hitchhiking you don't get to go exactly
where you want to go and you don't get
to go on your own time schedule and
that's important to a lot of customers
in five years time firefly plans to not
just be launching a rocket
but a family of rockets we are
interested in building a multi-billion
dollar business
and in order to do that we know that we
need to be cost competitive with
whatever the market throws at us
not just simply what the competition is
doing today
and one of those competitors is in long
beach california
virgin orbit is an offshoot of richard
branson's virgin galactic
space company and while they're a
medium-sized launch company just like
firefly and rocket lab their approach to
getting a rocket into orbit
is a bit different
virgin orbit is a dedicated small
satellite launch vehicle
that is seeking to revolutionize the
small satellite market
we're utilizing our flying launch pad
it's a boeing 747
400 aircraft that we modified and it has
an attached rocket under the left wing
of the plane it's a two-stage rocket
liquid oxygen kerosene rocket that has
been flown before and
and has many successes some of those
other successes are by their sister
company virgin galactic
who has used this launch pad drop
technology for space tourism
instead of small satellites which they
believe is a difference maker in the
industry
everything we built around the air
launch system is meant to mitigate
against
you know long-term delays for example an
air launch system can fly
in most weather conditions because we're
air launch
our cadence is very quick so it only
takes four to six hours to really fuel
the rocket
and attach to the plane and take off on
a mission and having that
flexibility having that quick cadence
turnaround time is critical to making
sure that payloads can get to orbit when
they want to get there
that flexibility is what most small
launch companies hope will set them
apart
that responsive rapid launch to exactly
where you want to go
that appeals to government users
government
mission scientific missions government
military missions
government intelligence missions are all
exploring the potential for
lower total cost small launch vehicles
that can do exactly
what they need when they need it and
without even having a successful full
duration test launch
virgin orbit already has a backlog of
customers
of course we see the market expanding
there's a lot of potential out there
so we certainly could see ourselves
providing even more launch support than
between 20 and 24 a year and of course
that is a more mid to long term goal
the future for companies like rocket lab
firefly and virgin orbit
looks promising but what about the
hundreds of smaller launch companies out
there
will everybody survive probably not
there's not enough demand
for a hundred and some odd rockets that
are currently in development
we absolutely believe that the window to
invest in launch has already closed
there are some investors who made some
early good plays here
that are going to work out very well but
at this point the
the industry is well past that kind of
venture capital
investment stage in our opinion so we
see it shaking out to
maybe 10 companies surviving the launch
industry is unforgiving
um it's not very tolerant of failures on
behalf of iron space
i wish to express my deepest apologies
to our customers for the loss
of their payload and telling them
how sorry i am if you're having a bad
a bad run of luck you don't get a whole
lot of patience out of the market before
people start using other rockets
the technology of space activities is
fascinating
the technological challenges are
extraordinary
the competence that it requires to
conduct
operations in space is intimidating
the launch industry has an energized
passionate collection of engineers
venture investors and designers
singularly focused on moving private
enterprise
off the planet it's not just a new
industry
but a new way of seeing the world and
working above it
once you have that cheap access to space
now you have entirely new business
models that close that didn't before
you have entirely new use cases for
space as an environment
you have an entire ecosystem of support
services that are developing to support
those satellites that are that are being
launched in the next
five to seven years and so that has kind
of unlimited amount of economic
development economic growth
possibility there you know i kind of
liken where we are right now to
to the very first beginnings of the
internet where we were just starting to
send emails
that that's really where we are in space
we're just starting to send emails
and if you if you think if you go back
when you know you just started sending
emails and if i said to you
all of the stuff that was going to occur
because of the internet you would you
wouldn't believe me right you would
think that's just crazy
but that that's where i think where
we're at right now is we've sent our
first email
and now space has opened up to
innovators to to really try new things
that's why perfecting the world of
launch is just the beginning
rockets aren't just providing a platform
for space flight
but a platform for innovation as we
figure out the business of how we get to
space
the next problem is where do we stay on
the next episode of giant leap
the international space station is
nearing its retirement
and nasa wants to open the door for
commercial companies to develop the
technology
and the business to create our next
space habitats
[Music]
you